on this episode I answer book questions
on my book day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 190 of the ask gary vee
show I have a fun idea for the editing
step on make sure I don't forget
vaynernation big heartfelt thank you I
obviously gave you a huge rant and at
the end of 189 we don't need to go
through that again so if you're watching
190 right now because we put out 189
late alright okay since we put out 189
late that episode ended with the
heartfelt thank you for everybody today
is booked day I am leaving in a second
to go to st. Louis I will see so many of
you tonight at a big big big book event
with my boy Andy looking forward to that
I will bring serious fire actually you
know what some time we haven't edited in
a while finally comes the meeting come
out of my mouth there we go
feeling good feels good about the book
last night CNN was good took a little
snapshot of politics India got a shout
out and CNN she was fired up
did he get any love from some of your
friends yeah amazing
could they New York this morning was
very feisty we should have that clip
shortly me and Greg Kelly got into a
young man old man conversation in my
opinion most people when they asked me
question are asking me to give them
encouragement to go for it because their
parents didn't build their self-esteem
okay that's a little bit respectfully
outside Europe know what's the field of
expertise totally disagree I mean look I
mean you're like me it's like an opinion
I have one you have one that's fine
that's your opinion now I'm gonna set
you straight and and here we are in the
end so here we are and I think that we
should go into it right let's do that
thing we do that's right let's get into
the show
your energy is not working this okay
let's go again I can't let's get into
get into the show there we go there we
go India let's do it Matt asks what was
the most difficult aspect about the
production of this book
what was the most difficult aspect of
the production of spoke as a matter of
fact this is probably the easiest book
I've ever written from a production
standpoint because so much of the
content had a framework one of the
things I'm most proud of is the
responses on social media and email this
morning of people that are stunned how
different it is than the actual show way
too much maybe a bad job by me way too
many people assuming that it was a
transcription from the show so you know
we took every question and the answer
that we differently shown and added a
hundred of them but the ones that came
from the show we reread I added
sentences context updated and so what's
the super hard stuff Leanne to
acknowledge in the book my ghostwriter
for the fourth business book in a row is
incredible she knows me were you know
we're we're a book married couple we
know how to jam with each other I did a
lot of it during my summer month in
August in the Hamptons so it was in a
very good place I was kind of like you
know get a cup of coffee in the morning
play with the kids a little bit and have
like a look they would go to camp and
just get in that place put on the
headphones call Steph and be like all
right Steph what's the question know
that what you have to do you know so I
would start off Zen but it went intense
very quickly it was great I mean you
guys were a big help we organized this
one was quite smooth I mean honestly
this could be the blueprint I mean if
this yeah scary me you know what a lot
of people don't know is the askgaryvee
show ends today and we're gonna be
transitioning to daily be and so with
the book launch I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm kidding I'm kidding
what's up what's a lot of fun is if this
show keeps going you know even though I
want to write perfectly parented even
though I want to write I wish everybody
was an immigrant even though there's
other books that I'd like to write I you
know I could see an S carry v book
volume 2 I mean this is a format that
could work I mean there were spa and II
the response is real there we go
India
oh so the shy should answer it the
toughest part
I guess the toughest part was the
pressure I felt to make it not a
transcription of the book that I really
and it's actually well I think the book
came out really strong I forced myself
to go to you know I love to talk in like
tweets and in like headlines and like
powerful punches I keep my second third
and fourth tier stuff normally for my
businesses askgaryvee the show made me
get into my second and third tier stuff
and I tried to force myself to get into
some fourth to your stuff in the book
Keith asks can you talk a little bit
about the outline slash organization
process of the askgaryvee book how did
you decide the best order of info step
land step land Steph watched the last
what step does extremely well as she
watches the last two years of my videos
I got on the phone with her and said
look these are the things that are
mattering to me you know we if you
remember you might have been on this ton
one big by the way big shout out this
time I text them last night before I
even texted you guys big shout at this
stunwin who was a big part of this book
you know obviously you know India killed
him and he is no longer around and so
but we miss him let him rest in peace we
love him very much
he's actually on floor 12 actually said
when he had chance I'm not even kidding
go down and capture him real quick just
so we can edit him in for a quick second
literally just roll up on him when he's
not managing get it and leave you know
he was a big factor I think we all got
him out if you remember there was that
to our calling remember I was somewhere
on a client thing where we talked about
what should the chapters be and I was
like you know grad for somebody sudden
patience didn't make it I'm like
devastated but you know we talked about
parenting and self-awareness and we got
a lot more into that EQ thing so we got
on to our call me and a team we all
talked about what the themes were about
150 episodes into the show we got into
them and they became the chapters and
then I had to call Steph and and
literally it was like okay clouds and
dirt and then I just talked I just
talked and then it was recorded she laid
it on grammar and away we went
Daniel asks what is the most humbling
thing that has happened to you through
this book's promotion I think the most
humbling thing is uh this is actually
very easy for me to answer
it's the extremities on both sides of
the equation of the audience that
consumes my content the people that know
me the the longest the Justin thorpes of
the world that are saying wow this is
really quality stuff you know people
that have listened to me for seven years
they fill my spiel I mean think about
you and Andy you literally watch me at
the 92nd Street Y the other day and you
know what's about to come out of my
mouth before it comes out like when
you're around somebody right and you're
consuming for the people that know me
the best to really get their $19 worth
because there's really more stuff cause
I forced it to level four and on the
other direction the people that are in
mainstream media the people that are a
little more cynical by DNA nature the
people that think I'm a loudmouth or
don't think that cursing is a
gentlemanly those people reaching out
and some of the heartfelt emails that
I've got in the last week of like I
don't I didn't believe in you and this
has caught me off guard or you know I've
never been a fan but I had to review
this for my website and I was blown away
or I never really understood that you
were anything more than a blowhard
promoter like just you know the extreme
like the two parties really into me
really not into me going
actually I guess this one I guess I
don't know nonetheless that has been
humbling in the fact that I know I've
created something really strong here
because um because I'm getting reactions
from both sides of the aisle and that um
that matters to me and that was a goal
and that feels good
when you accomplish a goal Tim asks what
surprised you the most about the success
of the book launch compared to your last
book thanks for all you do I don't know
I mean there's so many more of you guys
than there was with just me and Nate for
a jab jab jab I you know I I guess I
don't know if anything surprised me I
would say that my team starting with you
Andy you guys really really brought it
you really did like I'm really proud of
the team and a built momentum I think
you know Stefan answer like I could see
even like halfway through like like like
it just the whole team came together
like you guys really worked though
especially I think since the 1st of
January it really was rolling like I
think the other thing that surprised me
is that I hooked up I didn't have that
one organized a 30 day there was no
reason to have the cup of not having
that one organized and that's on me not
on you guys silicate look today
there was one there's one day that we
should have had that wouldn't have
allowed all the vulnerabilities that I
can think of now like there's literally
like 40 more people that I could add
right a medium review there's probably a
hundred more influencers that I'm like
yeah I said this yesterday you just
don't we said this Stefan at the end of
the LAV yesterday you as hard as you
leave it on the field there's always
like 15 other things you can think of
you know there's things that we did
better on jab jab that we didn't doing
this that I'm just like man you know so
you know just uh I guess what surprised
me it's not it's not what surprised me
the two observations are I'm so proud of
the team I thought they really brought
it and I'm used to being the strongest
energy and for the team to match my
energy or get close to it excites me and
then too
even with all that even when I think I'm
the best even with all that support
seven eight of you underneath me it
I literally right this minute can think
of 25 more thing
that we left on the table crazy just
can't get it to it and you know what
that's what's important I think a lot of
people beat themselves up for it
I recognize it because I want to give a
good answer on the show mainly because I
want to give you a proxy which is like
look you give it your at-bat and that's
what it is it's like you know when you
see an athlete retire right a lot of big
guys are retiring pay and Kobe all this
if you can get into that place where you
felt like look you left a lot of the
table you don't think Kobe and pain are
thinking right now about that one
championship they had you don't think
Kobe's thinking about that game seven
against the Celtics seems like Payne's
thinking about that Saints game like
they're thinking about it every second
of the day because that's what winners
do winners think about that but it
doesn't destroy them it doesn't become
cancer it's just something they love to
ponder while being equally massively
content that they left it on the field
and that's how I feel about this book we
did a really great job I'm really proud
of it there's 25 things I wish we did
that was deep I like that one cool last
one you're excited about this one
because this is gonna oh you like
cuteness you're too cute great no I just
I don't have you position as cute you
know I don't not that you're not cute I
mean that you do not enjoy like let's
have pink fluffy flowers thrown in the
air yes I know that that's why I'm
curious to see what this is let's see
help that's right look see how cute this
is
dandy asks what did it feel like to see
the book in stores today I haven't seen
it yet
great question India you know that I was
that's not be seeing it you lost
what's your the day the hell was India
knew it and I like I'm just kidding
question of the day yeah yeah but you
know what is actually in your world tomb
we're gonna do it together question of
the day tag the person that I should
give this book to give it away 100
copies on me you're gonna work with me
on this now these are people that 100
percent don't know about what's going on
here but you see from afar could benefit
from this we're gonna surprise some
peeps my friends we did this yesterday
too right
so there's some people that reply we're
gonna do four or five there but we're
going big today this is me giving back
to the vaynernation
to the people that are most important in
your life and things of that nature
we're gonna go hard at this Andy I
really want to surprise people I like
how people on Facebook live or like whoa
whoa they're gonna be ready for when
this goes up at a couple hours Steph
what do you think four hours from now
okay
Facebook YouTube it's Facebook YouTube
if you're watching go to Facebook
facebook.com slash Gary please tag the
person that you think needs this book
India put together a team Garrett Riley
so they reply in there they go hey
Stefan tags Terri rice you know Riley
and Garrett you have to go over whoever
we put the team on goes in here because
hey Terri rice tag them you know if you
di me your address we'll get the book
out to you let's make a hundred people
better you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
Thank You vaynernation go nope I have a
different plan for it see you later
[Music]